uh we have a kind of nice way to start
2022 in a very particular sense
amongst a lot of bad news and that's
that radical right lunatic republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene has
been permanently banned from twitter for
continuing to spread covet
disinformation now there are people
acting like we'll get to the people
saying this is fascism it's very funny
we'll get to that
people acting like this was on a whim
with no forethought or basis
this was her fifth strike
uh there's an article in the new york
times twitter permanently suspends
marjorie taylor green's account social
media service says she violated its
covet misinformation policy
um twitter suspended her account after
she tweeted on saturday falsely about
quote extremely high amounts of covet
vaccine deaths she included a misleading
chart that pulled information from a
government data database of unverified
raw data
called vares
a decade old system that relies on
self-reported cases from patients and
health care providers twitter said ms
greene had a fifth strike which meant
her account will not be restored
the company had issued her a fourth
strike in august when she falsely posted
vaccines were failing
she had a third strike a month before
that when she tweeted covid was not
dangerous
and vaccines should not be mandated
her official congressional account rep
mtg
remains active because tweets from that
account didn't violate the services rule
so just to go through it element by
element
i'm showing people the rep mtg account
that one has about 400 000 followers she
has not posted there since december 24th
where she posted a christmas message of
some kind um
i'll just play a few seconds of it and i
will warn you listening to her speak is
extremely triggering in a lot of
different ways on behalf of myself my
family and staff i want to wish all
americans and especially those in the
14th district okay i i already i mean
okay we're done with that
um there are some people reacting to
this in ways
that uh
don't don't really make a lot of sense
to me
um a lot of people are calling this so
so there's a but
i don't even know where to start first
there's people criticizing and saying
that we need regulation
twitter shouldn't be allowed to do this
um
why can't businesses have terms of
service that they enforce
and and that i mean that's just what it
is
there's a lot of confusion from people
who generally say businesses should be
allowed to do whatever they want as long
as it's not illegal and very few things
should be illegal who are saying
businesses shouldn't be allowed to
require vaccines well hold on can they
require that you wear a shirt yeah
can they require that you wear shoes
yeah
if you don't like it can you choose just
not to go there yeah
but they can't do vaccines okay doesn't
make sense that's one hypocrisy but then
the other one is
they are saying there should be
something that the government does
to prevent these businesses from
deciding for themselves what they want
to do as long as it's not illegal
now there's another aspect of this which
is people saying this is authoritarian
fascism
former guest brian class he's been on a
couple times and he was on a few months
ago he had a really great perspective on
this which you can find on twitter and
he wrote whenever twitter suspends
someone for spreading deadly lies
someone will call it authoritarianism or
fascism it's the opposite it's a free
market company making decisions without
government interference or directives
fascism is the inverse fascism is
extreme state control and brian goes on
to say there are complicated free speech
issues around social media which we all
i mean anybody who's thoughtful agrees
with that
but i can assure you says brian that
twitter couldn't make its own choices to
ban government officials somewhere like
north korea they would instantly be shut
down we don't have fascism here because
twitter can do this and at least for now
the government isn't saying you gotta
allow marjorie taylor green to lie about
vaccines or trump to do whatever
so let's be consistent
is it illegal
to do what twitter is doing it is not
well then by their definition if it's
not illegal it's okay and people can
choose to boycott uh there's many of you
might remember or know or you know
whatever that the david pakman show
started in the
city i grew up in northampton
massachusetts
and i still have a lot of friends in
northampton and recently there was a
hearing held by the northampton board of
health about businesses requiring
vaccines more and more businesses you
know i hear from friends this business
that business is requiring vaccines i
have friends who own businesses in
northampton they say we're going to
require vaccines of customers and they
had this this hearing via zoom and you
know people could comment on facebook
and and elsewhere
and you have all these people
making conflicting and different
arguments it's like you about this is
the worst decision ever this is this is
authoritarianism this is nazi this is
fascism this is all these different
things
break it down element by element is it
illegal for a business to
require proof of vaccines i don't even
care about does it do anything i've said
at this point this thing is so
contagious
that the vaccines primarily are
protecting people from serious illness
hospitalization and death it's still it
the cat is out of the bag this thing is
clearly going to burn its way through
whether there's a vaccine requirement at
a local restaurant or not but is it
illegal to require vaccines no okay
so now we're just in the realm of
opinion
you don't like businesses that require
vaccination then don't go to them it's
it's really that simple marjorie taylor
green knew what the rules were at this
point she chose to break them it's her
fault she should be banned that's it
officials don't get a special allowance
to spread disinformation about a public
health crisis because they're elected
officials
she was elected by georgia trumpists to
represent them it doesn't mean that you
get a national platform or global
platform to tell lies that violate the
policy of twitter
is twitter discriminating against people
on the basis of race when they do these
things no are they discriminating on the
basis of national origin no
if you don't like it you don't have to
use twitter that it that that's
fundamentally what it is and this really
does matter and what i mean by that is
when trump was banned from twitter
uh mango musa mussolini the tangerine
terror you guys remember the guy
the amount in general
of hate speech
went down the amount of people weren't
then re-amplifying the stuff trump was
putting out there so this works and it's
legal if you don't like it that's a
different story and if you want to
propose regulation of twitter of some
kind
i'm glad to discuss it
but then we have to be able to say we
should be regulating regulating all
sorts of different businesses that
right-wingers always say let them do
whatever they want as long as it's not
illegal as of right now i want to hear
from you guys um we'll post uh more
about this on our instagram you can find
us there at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is sheath underwear
it's summer right now in the northern
hemisphere it's hot it's humid many of
the men in my audience know about the
discomfort that can come with this with
traditional underwear the sweating the
chafing the sticking not fun and that's
what sheath underwear has solved sheath
has designed men's boxer briefs with
multiple ergonomic compartments built
into the front of the underwear which
keeps everything separate dry cool and
comfortable all day long
sheath has re-released two limited
edition styles
flower of life with a stylish flower
pattern and bold geometric waistband the
other limited edition style is the mesh
airflow especially designed to be
lightweight and promote extra coolness
and breathability give sheath underwear
a try i've had a great experience with
it i think you will too you can find the
link underneath this video and don't
forget to use promo code pacman for 20
off